mesdames messieurs bon dimanche qui n'a
pas été exaspéré par un électroménager
qui brise quelques mois à peine après la
fin de la garantie ou par un véhicule
neuf qui passe trop de temps chez le
mécanicien le gouvernement logo a déposé
la semaine dernière un projet de loi
pour protéger les Québécois contre les
citrons et l'obsolescence programmée
cette pratique ou un manufacturier
réduit la durée de vie d'un appareil
pour favoriser la charte d'un modèle
neuf le projet de loi forcerait les
fabricants à rendre disponible les
pièces de rechange et à faciliter la
réparation leurs appareils une
initiative saluée par les parties
d'opposition et par les groupes de
protection des consommateurs et de
l'environnement
en France à Paul a été condamné et a
payé 25 millions d'euros suite à avoir
fait l'observance programmée pour mes
choses en Italie 10 millions d'euros moi
j'y crois ça va me faire plaisir de
collaborer avec le gouvernement sur ce
projet de loi qui me semble parfaitement
adéquat sur le principe c'est certain
qu'on à Québec soldats ont lutte contre
le sens programmée depuis des années si
bon Alain barrette ministre de la
Justice bonjour merci d'être avec nous
bonjour monsieur
le sens programmé pourquoi s'attaquer à
l'obsolescence programmée parce que vous
savez les Québécois québécoises achètent
des biens de consommation notamment des
électroménagers ils dépensent des
centaines voire des milliers de dollars
et parfois les biens brisent après
quelques années seulement et c'est très
frustrant pour les Québécois puis il
faut que les Québécois en ait pour leur
argent donc l'obsolescence programmée
c'est une tactique qui est vraiment
néfaste et surtout dans un objectif de
faire en sorte de protéger
l'environnement il faut arrêter de
simplement acheter et jeter il faut
pouvoir réparer nos biens il faut
surtout en avoir pour notre argent
lorsqu'on achète un bien alors c'est
pour ça qu'on fait l'obsolescence
programmée bon la liste est vaste et
donnez-moi un certain nombre d'éléments
pour lesquels vous pensez que cette
loi-là elle est très importante elle
serait très importante et produit tous
les jours le que les gens achètent mais
j'ai un exemple la vaisselle
réfrigérateur cuisinière
laveuse sécheuse les téléphones les
appareils électroniques les tablettes
tout le monde a déjà constaté que
prenait les cuisinières dans le temps de
ma grand-mère ça durait pendant 25-30
ans aujourd'hui dans certains cas ça
brise après seulement quelques années
alors c'est pas normal c'est tactique là
alors je pense qu'il faut lutter contre
l'obsolescence programmée puis faire en
sorte clairement que on change le modèle
sur lequel les compagnies nous nous
fournissent les biens puis surtout aussi
faut s'assurer d'avoir une garantie de
bon fonctionnement c'est ce qu'on insère
dans le projet de loi vous avez mis les
voitures dans une catégorie à part
pourquoi
les voitures c'est un bien particulier
dans plusieurs en fait dans tous les
États américains il y a une loi
anti-stron et on reproduit le même type
de législation ici dans le cadre de la
loi côté qui ne connaît pas quelqu'un
qui a déjà acheté un véhicule et qui
s'est avéré un citron d'être abonné chez
le garagiste à le faire réparer à de
multiples reprises alors on va prévoir
pour les gens qui se retrouvent avec ce
type de véhicule que le concessionnaire
le fabricant va devoir le remplacer ou
diminuer le prix ou modifier le contrat
pour diminuer l'obligation du
consommateur même chose également on
prévoit dans la loi que désormais les
citoyens québécois va pouvoir faire
réparer son véhicule au garagiste de son
choix parce que avec les nouveaux
véhicules avec les véhicules
intelligents avec les véhicules
électriques de plus en plus c'est comme
un ordinateur sur 4 roues et là il y a
l'information pour se connecter au
véhicule ben souvent c'est uniquement
chez le concessionnaire du véhicule où
il a été vendu donc ça fait en sorte que
le consommateur est captif avec la même
marque donc ça on va changer ça
également pour va nous permettre de
faire réparer son véhicule chez qui on
le souhaite la tension elle est bonne et
les louable maintenant c'est un projet
de loi provincial petite échelle
pourquoi une multinationale qui fait des
réfrigérateurs pour l'Amérique du Nord
au complet ce souciait de ce que vous
êtes en train de faire à Québec ben
écoutez c'est une tendance mondiale en
Europe et adopté des lois pour faire
changer ça sur l'obsolation programmée
notamment en France l'Union européenne
également a mis des normes les
États-Unis également dans plusieurs
états il y a déjà ce type de législation
là il y en a qui sont à l'étude
présentement alors moi je pense que le
Québec a toujours été un chef de fil en
matière de protection du consommateur et
doit le demeurer et vous savez notamment
pour la loi de citron va être le premier
État fédéré au Canada à se doter d'une
telle loi puis moi je pense qu'on doit
protéger les consommateurs québécois on
doit également pour l'environnement
changer les façons de consommer faut
arrêter de faire uniquement du HT jeté
les gens doivent pouvoir avoir la
possibilité de réparer leurs biens puis
la question souvent québécois se posent
quand un bien qui brise ils se disent
ben écoutez si je le fais réparer ça va
me coûter quasiment plus cher que d'en
acheter un œuf c'est cette logique là
qu'il faut changer il faut que les
pièces soient disponibles comme on le
prévoit dans le projet de loi faut que
ça soit facilement réparable faut faire
en sorte que les outils qui vont
nécessiter la réparation mais ça soit
des outils simple comme les tournevis
que vous avez à la maison les pinces que
vous avez à la maison faut pas que ça
puisse endommager le bien lorsque vous
le faites réparer et dans le projet de
loi on a mis une garantie de bon
fonctionnement c'est une garantie qui va
venir mettre un plancher pour supposer
les électroménagers pour dire ben le
fardeau si jamais il brise il est sur
les épaules du fabricant c'est à lui de
le réparer assez frais ou de vous le
remplacer alors moi je pense que ça ça
va changer durablement la façon dont les
biens sont construits parce que on amène
un souci de construire durablement
sur la protection du consommateur
offrait pas déjà ce genre de protection
là pour certains biens mais actuellement
vous aviez la garantie légale cependant
la garantie c'est une garantie où la
démonstration est sur les épaules du
consommateur donc le bien doit
fonctionner pour l'usage auquel les
destinés cependant c'était au
consommateurs à le démontrer devant le
tribunal là on inverse le fardeau de la
preuve avec la garantie de pompe bon
fonctionnement et on vient simplifier la
vie des consommateurs québécois
cependant la garantie légale demeure
également donc c'est une garantie
supplémentaire qu'on ajoute mais ça
devrait devenir un automatisme pour le
consommateur et ça ça va permettre
d'avoir une garantie plancher pour tout
le monde sur une durée de vie d'un bien
est-ce qu'il y a un risque de prévu
qu'une compagnie dit vous savez quoi moi
j'ai pas envie de gérer ce genre de truc
là avec le Québec si jamais le projet de
loi est adopté je vais vendre pas au
Québec mes produits est-ce qu'il y a un
risque que les consommateurs québécois
doivent se passer de certains produits
non je ne le crois pas écouter c'est une
tendance mondiale je parlais des
États-Unis notamment dans plusieurs
États sont en train d'adopter ce type de
législation là je pense qu'on doit être
des chefs de fil puis vous savez il y
aura toujours des gens qui vont vouloir
vendre des cuisinières des Ré
vous allez faire des consultations vous
allez me donner des consultations pour
déterminer ce qui serait un délai
raisonnable pour permettre aux
manufacturiers de ces appareils là de
s'adapter ce coin de raisonnable d'après
vous ben écoutez dans un premier temps
on va faire des consultations sur le
projet de loi à l'automne par la suite
le projet de loi prévoit qui va rentrer
en phase sur quelques mois quelques
années notamment pour laisser le temps
ou fabricants de s'adapter à la nouvelle
échelation donc on va développer des
règlements au cours des prochains mois
j'aimerais vous entendre sur la loi 12
sur le droit de la famille qui est
adopté la semaine dernière parlez-moi de
la protection que ça accorde qu'est-ce
c'est très spécifique quand même comme
protection parlez-moi de ce que ça
accorde aux femmes dont l'enfant est né
d'un viol oui mais lorsque vous êtes
violé qu'un enfant qui est issu de ce
viol là la mère désormais va pouvoir
s'objecter à l'établissement de la
filiation par l'agresseur donc on laisse
le choix la mère de dire est-ce qu'elle
établie l'affiliation où il y a une
décharge autorité parentale on vient
également dire dans la loi informatif
grave de déchéance d'autorité parentale
pour faire en sorte que l'enfant ne soit
pas sous le contrôle de l'agresseur
alors on a fait ça mais on a surtout si
décidé de protéger les femmes pour
permettre qu'elle puisse avoir une
indemnité financière associée oui parce
que vous séparez les deux c'est ça il y
a pas de filiation mais il y a une
responsabilité financière à la part du
Père par exemple exactement il y a un
recours pour obtenir des aliments dans
le fond une indemnité financière pour
l'enfant puis déjà le programme
gouvernemental de l'IVAC l'indemnisation
des victimes nationales prévoit des
sommes qui sont prévues pour l'enfant
pour pour son alimentation pour son
éducation ça c'est un problème
gouvernemental que nous comme étant on
assume mais en plus on veut tenir
l'agresseur responsable donc pour donner
des ressources supplémentaires à la mer
l'autre point qui est important dans le
projet de loi ce qu'on a un amendement
qu'on a inséré ou durant l'étude
détaillée c'est le fait que lorsque un
homme agresse ses enfants ou agressent
tout autre enfant mineur mais il y aura
versement du fardeau de preuves au
niveau de la déchéance du tourte
parental ça sera plus à la mer dont les
enfants ont été agressés sexuellement
par le père de démontrer qu'il n'est pas
un bon père ça va être à lui à démontrer
qui doit conserver l'autorité parentale
pour les enfants ça je pense que ça
avait été décrit on le changeait et dans
le projet doit également on est venu
encadrer la grossesse pour autrui en
ayant
porteuses en ayant en priorité
la protection des marpoteuses qu'il n'y
a pas d'instrumentalisation du corps de
la femme que la femme puisse conserver
l'entière autonomie de son corps et
surtout également de protéger les
enfants
issus de la grossesse pour autrui je
donne un exemple les parents d'intention
qui avaient le projet parental donc qui
demandait de m'apporteuse de porter
l'enfant il pouvait partir dans brume
après trois mois de grossesse après 6
mois ou quand l'enfant venait au monde
il aurait pu abandonner l'enfant là on
est venu verrouiller tout ça pour dire
si vous avez un projet parental vous
allez devoir votre vie durant assumez
vos responsabilités par rapport à
l'enfant que vous avez conçu dans le
cadre d'un projet parental un mot
rapidement terminant sur la congestival
vous êtes en travaux intensif qu'est-ce
que vous voulez régler la vente partir
pour la pose la pose d'été ben écoutez
on a quelques dossiers qui qui doivent
être réglés notamment la question de la
du nombre de jeux à la Cour du Québec
vous savez qu'on a eu une entente avec
la courbe du Québec donc on est
présentement en train d'étudier le
projet de loi au cours des prochaines
semaines également on continue l'étude
détaillée du projet de loi 15 donc du
ministre de la Santé la réforme de la
santé également le ministre drivée avec
la réforme de l'éducation de temps
consultation puis le salaire de
l'augmentation de salaire des députés va
régler ça avant la peau estivale malgré
la production Québec solidaire sous
réserve l'adoption du Parlement ça
devrait être réglé sinon je vais
barrette ministre de la Justice merci
beaucoup Merci à VOUS bonne journée